this is the reality of life for migrants
arriving in cali
ramshackle camps full of people who've
been thrown together in packed
turbulence
what they share is a single ambition to
get across the channel for the people
here britain has a magnetic attraction
it's seen as safe and prosperous
and even if the government wants to make
it harder for these people to make a
life in the uk
there is a determination to try
were young teenagers when they fled
afghanistan they've spent three years on
the road
surrounded by the chaos of this camp
they tell me they're scared
well these camps are inevitably
transient unpredictable places but
recently they've become much more
volatile with violent confrontations and
shootings between migrants from
different nationalities almost certainly
instigated
by rival people smugglers smugglers use
familiar criminal tactics trying to
enforce loyalty through intimidation
and it is a wretchedly cruel industry
yeah eric runs a marine supplies
business people smugglers come to him
wanting to buy dozens of life jackets at
a time but they purchase 12 euro
children's versions
instead of those designed for an adult
he says he can't refuse to sell them
you're thinking that
these people are considering that life
is cheaper than 12 year old
uh you can't do anything
and if you do something
you may have big big troubles you can't
prevent you you can't call the police
because you're scared
because we are scared
from here you can glimpse dover's cliffs
through the haze
it's the target that brings so many to
these beaches year after year
adam parsons sky news cali